it's back in a big way after years of
fooling sales and irrelevance cool of
duty is going back to its roots it'll be
more shocking more morally ambiguous
than ever before with Russians so evil
you wouldn't believe
surprised russian su-25 jet there it is
apparently bombing civilians in the next
scene white helmets the rescuing of
serious jihadist rebels has seen helping
injured civilians out of rubble just
like in their real-life propaganda reels
the Syrian first responders who risk
their lives to save others in war-torn
Aleppo the face of unrelenting brutality
heroes have emerged they have all chosen
to risk their lives to save others now
it's only a trailer but something tells
me we won't see the ugly side of the
white helmets I doubt we'll see them
disposing of freshly executed corpses
for Islamist terrorists I doubt we'll
see them waving al-qaeda flags as they
do in real life I doubt we'll see them
staging chemical weapons attacks what I
don't doubt is that the Russians will be
portrayed doing things that would put
Satan himself to shame at least going by
what those have already played the game
saying we saw gameplay from the
perspective of a young Ferrara the girl
who would eventually grow up to be the
commander of the rebel forces fleeing
from the invading Russian army Farrah
and her family are eventually cornered
by a soldier who kills her father we see
Karim crawling under bed and squirming
around her house to take down and long
haired Russian soldier was little more
than a screwdriver to be fair it's only
a game artistic license and all that no
relation to real-life events people or
politics it's just a video game
for young malleable impressionable kids
showing imaginary Russians invading
bombing civilians murdering civilians
gassing civilians and being killed and
turned by the protagonist and the white
helmets virtually copy pasted from CNN
into Call of Duty coincidence total
what we say is what defines a terrorist
is in the eye of the beholder this is
not a black and white world
oh so Isis bombing an airport in Europe
doesn't necessarily mean it's terrorism
that's like real life dude we will
decide what's good and what's bad like
in previous Call of Duty games where the
player gets to Massacre hundreds of
Russian civilians in an airport
and again by total coincidence Call of
Duty and the Pentagon have almost
identical perceptions of who is good and
who is bad what I meant by coincidence
is the opposite of coincidence not only
a Pentagon employees brought in to help
design the game but cool of duty writers
then go on to advise that the Pentagon
started thinking about how to change
call of duty we brought in a lot of
outside help military advisers
futurologists we got together with a
scenario planner from the Department of
Defense who is active in the Pentagon
which of course means nothing it's only
a game for kids I just wonder when will
we get a modern warfare installment
where the protagonist is patriotic
middle eastern and fighting to rid his
country of an occupying American army
what do you think those Pentagon
advisers would have to say to that
respected Joe Lombardo coordinator at
the United National anti-war coalition
he claims the US military uses video
games as a propaganda tool I think it's
just part of the propaganda that comes
out in various forms to get people used
to war and to get people to take sides
especially young people propaganda comes
in very many forms and throughout my
lifetime I've seen movies and Hollywood
change and I think this is preparing
people for the kind of world that the US
military and the US government want to
see so they can continue their dominance
military dominance and political
dominance over the world the US military
should stay away out of the gaming
industry they should stay out of
Hollywood they should stay out of the
sports industry but they are in all of
those industries
you